but first i give the floor to the
president of the european council
europe
is
fundamentally
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
today we discussed three key areas
of eu canada cooperation provide 19
an economic recovery eu canada relations
and some international issues
today the world is at a crucial juncture
we see the resurgence of kovit 19
everywhere
so it's natural that curvit 19 and our
economic recovery
were at the heart of our agenda
we are determined to fight the pandemic
together
as a global community in line with our
values of democracy
human rights and the rule of law our
goal
is twofold first protect the health
of our citizens and second ensure
an innovative sustainable and inclusive
economic recovery and there is one
way to do this through solidarity
cooperation and multilateralism the work
of the g7
and g20 and the united nations are
crucial to these efforts the eu
and canada also cooperate on curved
vaccines
treatments and tests to make sure all
people have fair and affordable access
and we discussed strengthening
the wh who global pandemic
preparedness and response and the
necessary reforms
we welcome g20 efforts on debt relief to
support
the most effective low-income countries
especially in africa
this year we celebrate the third
anniversary
of the provisional entry into force
eu canada strategic partnership
agreement and the seta
the ceta has been good for both the eu
and
canada bilateral trade has increased by
24 percent for routes
and 25 percent for services and we hope
for the street stratification
of sita by all our member states
climate change may not drape the
headlines right now
but it's no less urgent today than
yesterday
we stressed the urgency to step up
global action to tackle climate change
and the eu and canada share the common
goal of achieving
carbon neutrality by 2050 and our
economic recovery offers a unique
opportunity for a green reset of our
economies
we also highlighted our close
collaboration on our digital
transformation
we work together to ensure that
artificial intelligence
and other digital technologies play a
role
in our curvit 19 recovery we also
discussed
a range of foreign policy and security
issues
including china belarus nader northern
eastern mediterranean sail and venezuela
the eu and canada see eye to eye
on these issues specifically on china
we have serious concerns about the human
rights situation in china
including the arbitrary detention of eu
and canadian citizens strengthens
atlantic relations are critical to
address today's
geopolitical challenges and uphold the
rules-based double order
that we both cherish we also agreed to
cooperate
in protecting our democratic systems
against cyber attacks
and disinformation our eu canada
relationship
is strong and cut in the values of
democracy
human rights and multilateralism and
we look forward to expanding our
cooperation at our next
summit when conditions allow
thank you mr president i'm now returning
to the bellamon building for madame
president
i would like to start by also condemning
in the strongest possible terms
the hideous and brutal attack which took
place in east today
my thoughts are with the victims of this
appalling act
no one should doubt europe's solidarity
with france
we are united and determined in the face
of fanatism
and barbarism
and i would like to thank prime minister
minister
justin trudeau for the very good
conversation we had
it is always a pleasure to talk to
like-minded partners
and of course the european union and
canada have traditionally a very close
relationship
so we are partners we are partners who
are facing a challenging international
context
we are partners who are ready to tackle
the existing global challenges
through cooperation and multilateral
approach
our video conference today was a very
clear message about this relationship
and i'm happy to state that our
cooperation is increasing on a number of
issues
so canada is a very essential ally for
the european union
in the areas of foreign policy of trade
and climate action
just to name some but also innovation
digital research
was an important topic today so in the
talks we had today
we underlined the necessity to work
closely together on all these issues
but also to uphold the international
rules-based
system we had also
a conversation on agreeing on
cooperating closer in protecting our
democracies
and and being very firm on
fighting cyber attacks and
disinformation
so i want to thank prime minister justin
trudeau for his very strong support
to international efforts to fight
coronavirus one of the main topics of
our talks the cooperation on this
between the european union and canada
has been excellent it has been excellent
both on a bilateral level
and on the multilateral level so
canada has been participating from the
very beginning from day one on
in the pledging events thank you very
much for that
this support was crucial then
we were the very first ones to work
together
in creating what is today the act
accelerator
so a global construction to work closely
on a multilateral basis together
to go into the research and development
of vaccines
treatments and diagnostics and
i'm very grateful for canada's
significant political and financial
commitment
to kovacs because through this
the european union and canada are
cooperating to ensure
universal equitable and
affordable access to covet 19 vaccines
treatments and tests
and right now 184 countries
joined so far corvex this is a big
success
and this is solidarity cooperation and
effective multilateralism
those three are essential to defeat the
virus and to accelerate
the recovery
we will have next year in g20
hosted by italy a global health
summit and i was happy to
invite the prime minister justin trudeau
to come to the global health summit
it is a very important event because at
this
this g20 global health summit we want
to look at the lessons we've learned how
to deal with this pandemic
so another step forward in close
cooperation
in this context we stress that with
next generation eu the recovery
fund of the european union and
the european green deal the europeans
we want to be a driver in another
transition
a transition that is crucial for our
planet and crucial for our societies
it's a transition to a climate neutral
but also resource efficient and if
possible circular economy
across the world together with
like-minded partners
and we are very encouraged by canada's
announcements
related to climate change so we
count on canada and we know that we can
rely on canada
to work closely together with us on the
climate agenda
in particular we discussed that the
circular economy the resource
efficiency and for example renewable
energy including hydrogen energies of
the future
our cooperation has not only bilateral
but also significant
global potential so likewise we discuss
the digital
agenda it is good to see that our
dialogue is entering a new phase by
advancing research in particular on
quantum technologies and artificial
intelligence so both fields where a
close cooperation is needed
both the european union and canada the
statistics prove it
the president of the council just named
the figures
so it is good for us and
it brought a trade increase between the
european union and canada
and we are determined to continue the
implementation
of ceta as an important tool in
strengthening
the economy but also the post-covered
economic recovery
on both sides this is a strong bridge
between canada and the european union
so we agreed to task our respective
trade minister
to explore further avenues to increase
the benefits of this agreement
for both sides so there are many tasks
ahead of us
in this regard i'm very happy to
announce that the european union is
taking the steps
to fully implement the conformity
assessment protocol
we have been waiting for that it was on
our side to act so this is a win-win
situation for both sides it will cut red
shape
and it will therefore also cut costs and
delays for canadian and european
european companies so we can now ensure
swift progress it is good to know
that in dealing with
canada we can rely on a very good
partner it is for us a very important
relationship
thank you very much for the summit today
and i give back the floor to the other
side of the street
thank you madam president and we're now
turning to ottawa
for prime minister trudeau prime
minister you have the floor
merci ratus
the
19 cases rising in canada and around the
world
job one is keeping people safe
canada and the european union have
already committed to the kovacs
initiative
for global access to vaccines today we
agreed to strengthen that cooperation
including on research access procurement
and distribution of covet 19 vaccines
i'm looking forward to continuing these
very important conversations about
protecting
people's health in our meeting we also
discussed
our shared work on the economy over the
last three
years the canada eu trade agreement has
created good jobs on both sides of the
atlantic
with canadian exports to europe up by 20
percent
today we talked about the work to be
done on fully
implementing sita to ensure that all
canadians
including farmers small medium-sized
businesses
and women entrepreneurs benefit fully
from this deal good progressive
trade will be key to rebuilding a strong
economy
that works for everyone through ceta
we can also create more green jobs
in fact canada will host the sita
clean tech summit driving our work
together to build
competitive growth as we fight climate
change
we also had a discussion on energy and
natural resources
with a particular focus both on
investments in hydrogen
and on canadians canada's mining sector
as a reliable source of minerals
critical to a cleaner attack future
lastly president michel president
vandalian
and i discussed the defense of shared
values like
democracy human rights and the rule of
law
now more than ever we must push back
against authoritarianism
and isolationism while securing
democratic norms
we agreed to work together to protect
our democratic systems against
cyber threats and disinformation while
addressing the arbitrary detention
of our citizens on that note i want to
thank president michelle and president
fonda lyon for their continued
and vocal support for the release of
michael kovrig
and michael spavar
canada
mercy
we're going to turn to the q a session
now and um
may i kindly ask you to switch on your
cameras
and point out to whom you want to
address your question to
we'll first take a couple of questions
here from the eu
accredited journalists i have a nick
guttridge as the first one to ask a
question nick
you have the floor
i am friends thank you very much um
to the um the presence of the the
commission and the council if i
please unsurprisingly on um on the uk
aspect
um did you discuss sort of uh you know
future relations
with the uk today and obviously the
the you know this is very important in
terms of relations with canada as well
um and so the president's you know with
time running so short in the the brexit
talks
um do you intend to sort of get
personally involved
next week and to speak to prime minister
johnson
and just quickly to prime minister
trudeau if i may um
do you think that a continuity trade
agreements with the uk
what we call a rollover is going to be
agreed in time
for the end of the year thank you
seo as you know we fully trust our
negotiator
michelle barnier the negotiation the
negotiations are
ongoing at the moment and we follow
closely with the point of the commission
uh the development and we'll have the
occasion probably
next week to assess uh what's the the
situation
you know what's the european position we
are united
uh we are working in order to make a
deal possible with the uk
but at the same time there are some very
difficult topics
which are very important for the
european side the level playing field
governance and also the fisheries but we
trust michelle barney
and we will see in the next days what
are
we hope the positive developments
madam president indeed uh the chief
negotiator
michelle barnier does a fantastic job
we are in very close contact um on an
hourly basis
because the negotiations now have been
intensified
since one week ongoing we are in a
critical phase now
and it's boiling down indeed to the two
topics
um that are the most important that is
the level playing field on one
side and the fisheries on the other side
but i want to remind that there are
11 other fields of files
that have to be negotiated till the very
end
we're making good progress but the two
critical issues
level playing field and the fisheries
there we would like to see
more progress we are now in depth in
detailing out how could we construct
a system that is fair for both sides
for a level playing field which is
conditions
to have the for the uk
a access to the single market that is
quota free and tariff free so the one
goes hand-in-hand with the other here
the question of how do we construct
the system on both sides of the channel
with the dispute mechanism
and with clear rules on both sides
this is crucial this will be in the next
day the field
to work deep into
and turning to ottawa for the prime
minister
to add a few lines maybe
thank you very much uh nick you probably
know that canada is extremely pleased
to be the only g7 country that has a
free trade deal with every other g7
country and
we would certainly like to keep that
there have been
many discussions over the past years
between
uh myself and prime minister johnson and
his predecessor
on that seamless transition on a
rollover of
the sita uh between canada and the
european union to be
the basis for a canada uh canada uk
uh free trade agreement that would allow
certainty for canadian
and british companies going into the
future
i think you've heard uh that there are
significant complexities
uh that the u.s the uk story is
grappling with
in terms of uh negotiating the
post-brexit agreement
with the european union i can highlight
that it's fairly straightforward with
canada and
we are certainly very optimistic uh in
the ability to see
uh things roll over smoothly uh the uk
uh is engaged in many
different negotiations right now but
canada is certainly there
to ensure this certainty uh that can be
given to
british companies at least with canada
as other things are worked out in a more
complex way
thank you turning to david carretta
david yes thank you very much david
carrett
radio radical italian radio
in it's it's a question for both
presidents and the prime minister in
five days time uh a country
which is or was a partner of the eu and
canada
will will vote after
four years of a difficult relationship
would you like to see a change
and do you think that the change would
be possible with the
actual president thank you
in any case we will show respect for the
choice
which will be made by the the american
voters
and you know that for for europe the
united states is
an important ally and indeed we
want in the future we want to work very
hard in order to
to develop a strong partnership or
strength alliance
we know that in the past we had some
different opinions on different topics
like climate change
like the trade questions like also the
situation
uh in in in some parts of the of the
world but in any case
we are totally convinced that it's good
for the future if it's possible
uh to have a strong alliance with the
united states this uh
our choice this our political will and
we will respect what will be
the choice made by the brit by the the
american voters
madam president you have the floor yes
thank you there is a good
tradition not to commend before
national elections and this shows indeed
the respect
for the american voters to decide and
of course the respect for the result
that is there
the united states are a very important
partner for the european union we are
allies
we share the same values we have a long
common history of very good excellent
cooperation
indeed there are issues um where
we are discussing uh the differences
that we have in specific fields for the
next
uh term in the united states
in the relation between the european
union and the united states
we are looking forward to more
engagement on the multilateral scene
for the rules-based multilateral system
that is far as important we are looking
forward to engage
stronger in the fight against climate
change
it is impressive to see how
states or regions or cities
step up against the climate change so to
engage in the fight of climate change
there we would like to have a closer
cooperation
but also the development of the digital
work world
is a common subject between us and of
course
to stand strong together to defend our
values
thank you mr prime minister
like people in countries around the
world canadians are watching closely
the elections in the united states and
like people around the world we won't be
commenting on
possible outcomes our responsibility as
a government
is to prepare for different eventual
outcomes and that's what we're focused
on every step of the way
as we've been able to uh over the past
many years
we will continue to stand up and defend
canadian interests
look for greater opportunities for
cooperation look to deepen the
already close ties between canada and
the united states
regardless of the outcomes our
responsibility is to be there
to push for better opportunities for
canadians and
a more peaceful more stable global
context and we will continue to work
with whomever the americans choose as
their president
to move forward in constructive ways
thank you we're going to stay in canada
the next couple of questions
will be asked by madeleine blase morin
from radio canada
says
um
fundamentals
for me it is very clear
first of all free speech free expression
are fundamental rights that have to be
defended
second the european union respects
religious beliefs and the third point
is the bridge because i'm convinced that
we have to be very clear that we will
never accept
violence that is hiding behind religion
true religion is peaceful and true
religion
is united
[Music]
yes i'm not i'm now going to ask the
question in english but mr
kudo if you could respond both in french
and in english
what is the plan for recognizing or
waiting to recognize the result of the
u.s
election if it's close
contested or questionable claims of
victory
uh first of all let me say
the terrorist attacks uh in france
are absolutely unacceptable they were
heinous
criminal acts unjustifiable by
any circumstances and an affront to all
of our values
we stand with everyone around the world
in
condemning this unacceptable violence
the criminals the terrorists the
cold-blooded murderers who perpetrated
these attacks
do not represent islam
they do not get to define muslims
we will of course be watching election
day
unfold in the united states with
confidence in american democracy and
their
democratic traditions that have managed
this event uh every four years for a
very very long time
successfully there have been situations
uh
in 2000 for example where it was a
matter of weeks before
arriving at a final outcome uh and as we
did then we will
um you know follow along carefully
without uh intervening interfering or
intervening
uh in uh well-established uh processes
uh internal to the united states
democracy
thank you mr prime minister this
concludes our press conference
thank you to all for joining us check
our websites
for the joint press release and see you
soon
[Music]
you